you you like violate this rule that I
have for myself and uh you you do it so
wonderfully which is focus or at least
it appears as as you do you like launch
like I don't know how many companies a
year do you launch eight eight goddamn
[Music]
all right we're live Kevin do you this
is Kevin Ryan do you remember me
I don't remember where we met I know
we've met but I don't remember where
that's good okay you don't have to
remember so basically I'm gonna tell you
why this is funny so basically I've
studied you for maybe 10 years so you
started uh you were the president of uh
and CEO of doubleclick which had like a
billion dollar plus exit and then you
have started like four or five companies
that are one's worth I think 28 billion
today one's worth uh uh you have a
couple billion dollar exits but you
started Business Insider and I cold
emailed you maybe 50 times and one of
those times because I admired you so
much and we'll talk about your career
but I wanted to be like you and one of
those emails you finally replied and you
just said like thanks for the updates
whatever and then I lied and I said I'm
gonna be in New York tomorrow can I get
20 minutes of your time and you let me
do that and I came to your office for
literally 20 or 30 minutes we had such
an impactful conversation and then you
did another follow-up call with me and I
have the notes from those calls and this
was in 2007 team and you made a bunch of
predictions about my life as well as the
media business and a few other things
that were 100 true and I refer back to
that note sheet on a consistent basis to
help make some decisions oh interesting
I'm glad sometimes I get lucky and I get
it right and you want to know what your
your PR people cold email us to get you
on the Pod so the tables have turned my
friend welcome to my world
but I just want to say like I've admired
you for a long time you're you're a
really big deal to me and so I'm so
happy that we're able to like finally do
this this is awesome and Kevin uh you
don't know me but I I did not stalk you
I did not cold email you in fact I was a
little bit uh just jealous of you
because I was at the time working in a
um when Sam was telling me about you I
was working at a startup incubator
studio and so we were launching four or
five companies a year and
um after three or four years I was like
I don't know if this model even works I
just feel like it's like this because
there's something inorganic about the
studio model versus like just a normal
startup that that comes from an
entrepreneur solving their own niche and
he's like well I don't know this guy
Kevin Ryan seems to do it he's cranked
out four or five billion dollar
companies out of this and I was like I
guess I should shut up and uh just you
know not the model that's the problem
it's me uh so you know I I think not
only is it cool that you built Big media
companies it's cool that you made the
stuff the studio model work when very
few people have been able to do that
yeah no no I still enjoy it uh by and
large it's still working you know things
go wrong it's not I wouldn't say it's
easy but we have a lot of companies that
are doing really well in different
sectors and so that's what's so fun and
look there there are more things to be
done there are many problems in society
that have not been solved and basically
the high level story of you is you uh
you had like a normal corporate career
but then you kind of like worked your
way into uh double click which
eventually I think became AdWords at
Google exactly right yeah so Google
bought it for about three billion
dollars in 2007. uh the company started
in 1996. I was there for nine years it
was public for seven years first four
year years went from 10 people when I
joined to 2000 we're so crazy in 25
countries so that's why I said my early
30s doing
um then we spent three years bringing
back to a thousand people as the
internet collapsed and 70 percent of our
clients went bankrupt so don't do that
uh then we we had huge market share
controlled basically ad technology and
so then Google bought it and then I
started uh Business Insider you know
and guilt I want to point one
thing out in this journey by the way
your career starts at Prudential uh so
shout out to all the listeners out there
who are in boring companies right now
boring huge companies consultants and
bankers out there there's hope for you
yet
um so you did like Prudential Euro
Disney blah blah and then you join
double click as employee 20 but you you
they brought you in I guess as a senior
person at the time yeah yeah what
happened is I had launched an internet
website four ew scripts which is a media
company and I was the CEO and CFO of a
division of that company wasn't it
basically just like Gilbert Comics or
exactly yeah Gilbert comics and we had
other Comics we owned peanuts and a lot
of other ones but on a relative basis it
became very successful as a website we
sold advertising uh e-commerce uh so
things that were not that easy to do
because we didn't have the vendors at
the time so I went to the parent company
and said look we should build up an
internet Division and they said no
because I thought you know I actually
believe that the internet's going to be
a huge which is obvious now but you know
a huge part of the next 25 years I want
to go do this full-time so I was gonna
go start a company I ran across
doubleclick that was already in the ad
Tech space they convinced me to join
them instead of starting my own company
I became the the CFO the president and
then the CEO and then when we met you
basically you you kind of outlined after
selling double click you said basically
my partner Dwight and I
we came up with this thing where we
called it alley Corp and we're like you
we get like two or three maybe even one
good idea a year and then we find good
people and we give them three hundred
thousand dollars and we say you have six
months let's see if we can make this
work together and you did that with
Insider Business Insider which I think
had a 500 million dollar exit you did it
with Zola which is still running and
it's kicking ass I believe you did it
with with Gil yeah which I think got to
like 500 million in sales but it didn't
end up working out wonderfully I think
you said yeah when we sold for 250
million which was less than we thought
but it's still obviously a you know a
real number good yeah great and then you
you can go ahead and correct me but
you've done this with like four or five
companies I remember this meeting from
2018 I said 300 000. that was wrong
right yeah so we started each company
with a million dollars so 500 000 from
each one of us and that was for Guilt
Business Insider and uh and then
we I did after that Dwight semi retired
and so I did that with Nomad I did that
with Zola and now by now I put about a
million and a half dollars in each
company when we start them which isn't a
significant amount of money for how big
I mean mongodb right now is trading I
think I think it's market cap is 26
billion dollars today I'm sure it's at
covet Peak it was like 40 or 50. that's
not a lot of money for the outcomes no
no and hey look we had to raise a lot of
money I mean between being a
private and public company raised and
lost a billion dollars before they had a
profitable quarter and now already make
300 million dollars a year in profits so
that's why it's so valuable is because
it's a it's just an incredible copy
growing quickly enormous market share
and is going to grow for the next 10
years it'll be a 50 billion dollar
company well you told me in our call you
said
one of my notes is basically if you're
not hiring fast enough and and by the
way this is like this is the VC route
but you said if you're not if you're not
hiring fast enough and losing money AKA
investing you either haven't figured it
out or you don't believe that your idea
is good enough
um and so you need to go grow faster
well anybody you you don't want to grow
fast just to grow fast if you have a
good idea and if you're hiring a
salesperson who costs 150 000 and
they're selling 500 000 worth you need
to hire those people all day long
because you have an opportunity and if
you have other products to create you
should hire these Engineers to to build
it so again it's not spending money to
spend money but if you're building a big
company it's going to take eventually a
thousand people or two thousand people
to do a billion dollars in Revenue well
and your analogy was you go look if I if
my idea is good enough I'm going to
build a machine that turns one dollar
into two dollars and if I have that
machine what are you gonna do you're
gonna go get as much money as you can
and back that truck up into that machine
and dump it in there exactly
now there are times in various companies
where it doesn't make sense to invest a
lot more money because we're not getting
the return yeah you run out of market
share uh it's not as big a market as you
think something's not working as well
and so then the right thing to do is to
not invest and I have companies right
now that we've cut 30 of the people in
the last year because given this market
and what they were doing we had too many
people so there's also a note in that
call that I thought was really useful so
I'm looking at Sam's notes from your
cold like back in 2016 Sam's building
the hustle he's trying to figure out
what to do next I I assume you were
considering raising money because you
wrote this down and I thought it was uh
um it's obvious when you hear it but I
most entrepreneurs I don't think think
this way which is you said let's say
you're going to raise two million
dollars at a 20 million evaluation so
you're going to dilute 10 percent and
you're saying you just have to ask
yourself if I took that two million
dollars and I invested it into growth
people whatever over the next 18 months
is our company going to be worth more
than 10 versus if we do not and if it is
then I need to do that I should do that
trade and if it's not I should not and
uh to capture the the logic properly
there yeah no exactly that's what you
have to look at and you know you don't
you don't want to raise too much in that
round because if you sold 10 million
then that's very expensive Capital if
you think it's going to be worth 100
million dollars someday or 200 million
dollars you should raise that money
later but you do need to get moving and
time is never on your side you know any
good idea I've come up with eventually
even if it was six months later three
other people are going to come up with
the same idea so you need to move
quickly people tend to they people most
people understand the the risk of doing
something
they understate the risk of not doing
something can you tell us a story where
moving fast either benefited you or cost
you big in one of these races that you
ran absolutely so double is the perfect
example we expanded to 25 countries
before our first country was profitable
so if we were a big company everyone
would have said look let's wait and see
and make sure our model works
but the result was if you were Procter
and Gamble or caterpillar or IBM who did
you work with you worked with us because
we had operations in 25 countries and
you have off offices in those countries
you didn't work with our competitor who
had offices in six countries
as a result we swept the market we lost
a bunch of money but we were able to
fund it and that is the reason today 25
years later that you know uh Google
still hasn't commanding shares because
we got it early on and it's never been
given up
but you're taking a chance I mean there
are times when you invest in something
and it doesn't work that well and you're
like wow we should have waited you don't
have time to wait what Insight was
Insider Business Insider was that so you
sold double click you back then when you
and I met you actually told me how much
money you made off the doubleclick sale
I won't say it unless you want to say it
but did you
um which I thought it was amazing that
you told me this I was like damn this
guy's helping me out so much by telling
me all this information did you you and
Dwight get together to start I don't
know if you call it an incubator or
whatever you call Alley Corp but did you
was Insider the first idea that you had
and what led to that what led to the
insight to start that yeah so The
Insider idea was so simple that you
can't even give us credit for it so this
is 2007. I love business Publications
and media Publications so I I'm sort of
a compulsive reader of that and I didn't
have the publication I wanted and it's
so hard to to remember for people today
that the Wall Street Journal and
business week at the time did not
basically did not update their websites
during the day that's crazy are you
thinking that's impossible and the
reason is that they were still on that
schedule of the paper comes out the
night you know the the morning articles
have to be done late at night and so at
10 and 10 a.m no one's updating it yet
and so they just did not adapt it and
don't forget uh your wheelie got mobile
phones in 2008
and so then all of a sudden all day long
you're in the taxi of course you want to
get an update on what's Happening so we
the things we did are so obvious and
done today but they were we were early
which is updating things continually
writing stories that were not complete
in a way we'd hear a rumor that X
company was buying white company we'd
say that's what we're hearing and you
know what happens when you write that
someone from that company calls this
yeah actually it's true
um and so then you get more information
and so you maybe write four or five
stories during the day as you get more
and more information and we also had a
point of view so you know we'd write uh
so and so just overpaid for a company
it's more important that we have a smart
point of view than that we're right in
the long term
and so and we did a great job of making
sure we showed up in search results so
again everyone does that today at the
time no one cared about headlines
because if you had Business Week
Magazine does the headline result in
more revenue for you no
but when we we would a B test three
headlines very quickly on a story and
realize what was working and so you know
what I'm proudest of is that Business
Insider is at 300 million uniques today
and never spent one dollar in
advertising
yeah you told me well you said you you
said we were just we were gonna just
turn out these articles which
um is common now but you go you had this
really cool Insight you go it's kind of
like Honda in 1985 versus General Motors
Americans laughed at the Honda uh car
they said this is just too flimsy this
isn't good but they're gonna like
capture some market share and they're
going to improve and you said it's kind
of like that with Business Insider the
the the quote the critics or the the
real people in the industry whatever you
want to call them they laughed at you
and they said this is just low quality
this is junk and you're like but we're
gonna get more traffic than you and I
think it took like five years or
something but we got more traffic than
Wall Street Journal and now they're
looking at us like holy crap you
surpassed us and we could afford to have
more substantial journalism that maybe
is taken more seriously if if that's
even uh I would guess by 2015 we had
seven people covering military and
defense
that's deep coverage I mean you you you
have a lot you're writing great stuff in
the beginning obviously we had you know
five journalists covering the whole
world it's not going to be amazing but
that that is a good parallel and we the
product didn't get better over time we
started winning Awards uh but it always
was intended to be a different
positioning it was punchier it appealed
to younger people uh it was opinionated
you know it was just a different product
uh but I think I think the company you
know we Henry Blodgett who's still the
CEO has done an extraordinary job in
over 15 years and a lot of these
insights came from him he was one of
seven people I interviewed for that job
and he killed it uh what'd you see in
him that uh made you pick him yeah I
knew if you remember it was a bold
choice because Henry had had some issues
on Wall Street
um so we some people felt like he was
tainted I knew that in the the issues by
the way were I think he got accused of
was it insider trading
at all what happened was at the time it
was standard there was that the Wall
Street analyst would come pitch the
company that was going to go public and
they would say look we're going to Great
write great things about you which is
potentially a conflict with their
recommendations to their uh their their
companies their investors so
um everyone did that Henry actually
wrote internal emails saying I feel
really uncomfortable with this
which then was used against him you know
no one else did that and so legally I
don't think he did anything wrong uh I
everything he wrote was approved by his
superiors and and order but anyway uh
you know some people felt like he was
tainted I didn't at all
um what I did know is he was an
incredible writer and he was a
perceptive journalist he was writing
pieces for the Atlantic I mean he's just
so good I mean he's so talented and he
also he truly understood internet
journalism so the people I interviewed
for the Wall Street Journal basically
just wanted to redo the Wall Street
Journal and which we don't need uh Henry
had was was fresh he had never really
worked in a newsroom which could be
viewed as a weakness I've eaten it as a
strength and so he changed the rules and
we were willing to do that and he did an
incredible job you know that same
strategy of kind of like start with the
content quickly that gets traffic don't
try to be don't look for kind of like
the peer Acclaim in the industry look
for what the market wants and then over
time improve the quality that was also
BuzzFeed strategy but today I'm looking
at the BuzzFeed stock it's 36 Cents it's
a 50 million dollar market cap what do
you think they got wrong or what
happened to BuzzFeed because it seemed
like they were they had that whole that
same Playbook and Jonah pretty if you
ever hear him talk he seems like you
know whip smart in the same way
for me it's very clear and I felt this
from day one even when they were
theoretically worth two billion dollars
I rarely ran into someone who said I
love reading BuzzFeed every day I I
don't believe they built up a true brain
they showed up in search results they
got traffic
but there were many many people that
religiously read Business Insider every
single day so it just had a brand that I
think was much stronger and more defined
and you you guys have another uh funny
part about you which is I was telling my
wife this because we were talking I was
telling her I was going to talk to you
and I was gonna and I followed Dave
Portnoy on Twitter from Barstool
Business Insider is the only one to get
one up on him so you guys had this you
guys had this article about some some
stuff that he had done and he went ape
he went crazy and Business Insider
had the best response which was no
response you guys didn't reply to
anything and it's the only time I've
ever seen Dave Portnoy get one up uh I
wasn't really involved with that whole
exchange that happened after
and I we sold the company so well I
thought it was pretty funny and I uh I
thought it was I thought business that
are actually handled it wonderfully and
they were the first people that I saw
that got one over on him you know you
know Kevin um you you guys have had so
many hits come out of the studio and um
as somebody who ran a studio for six
years and uh did not have billion dollar
Hits come out of it
I gotta know what's the uh what's the
secret what you know what was it that
you guys were doing differently and I'm
sure you've talked to many other people
you've seen many entrepreneurs start
these labs and you've probably seen the
same results that I have which is that
very very few
come up with anything that works what do
you think you guys did differently than
others so it's not that you know
detail-wise we did anything differently
at the end of the day this is a simple
business but hard to do in other words
you need a good idea and you need a good
team
uh so that's just there's nothing else
uh so you know we've had some good ideas
uh we do a lot of research you know any
one time we're doing deep dive so
someone will spend two and a half months
interviewing 50 people doing the same
thing that I would do if I were an
entrepreneur about to start a company so
we have a lot of knowledge there's a 50
page DAC we've really gone into it and
then we're committed and then we go hire
a great team and we help that team
but again it's a little bit like
watching you know I don't know a good
basketball player a good soccer player
we know what they do we can see what
they do can I do what they're doing not
very easily so I think we've executed
well there yeah I mean you know we have
a bunch of people including myself have
a lot of experience doing this it's just
a series of judgment calls you know I
think uh I'm able because the track
record and able to convince some good
people to be CEOs
um that's important too and we you know
we spend a lot of time helping them so I
chair 12 companies so about half my time
is spent focusing on those 12 which are
12 of our most valuable companies uh to
really guide them and make sure that
they do as well as possible walk us
through like one of those ideas so okay
so here for example two and a half years
ago so I'm uh I'm very interested in
psychedelics or mental health I'm the
leading funder of the Yale Center for
psychedelic research you know I'm
involved with a bunch of things
non-profit research for you know pushing
psychedelics forward so they can be
legalized either by by the FDA or by
state
so with that context two and a half
years ago I said let's do a deep dive
and see if we come up with a for-profit
idea the first on my team works with me
interviews 50 people yeah we're talking
to everyone and we come up with a
solution that was partly influenced by
some of the work that's been done at
Yale and we start a company called
transcend the person on my team actually
which is unusual spins out to become the
CEO uh Blake Mandel big article in uh
the Wall Street Journal about five
months ago about transcend because we we
started off with a million half dollars
but we raise 40 million dollars about a
year to a year and a half later in two
tranches at 80 million free
so big big big big step up big valuation
and we have a compound that you haven't
heard of going through the FDA process
it's in phase two trials right now
uh and so people are obviously
optimistic about the future like the
team like the execution uh we did some
things very well there we have been
awarded patents for example you follow
this industry you know that you can't
patent MDMA or mushrooms because those
have been around for a long time but we
actually did get a patent for meth alone
which is the compound that we're working
on uh so so far so good now there's
still risk but that company is you know
we currently have a 50 million dollar
position based on our 5 million that
we've invested so far and we think it
has a lot of potential what about um
like with mongodb so
um that was started I think in 2007 so
Ali Corp was like a little bit early did
you have a team helping you research
ideas back then I didn't that was purely
Dwight myself and Elliot Horowitz who
was the most brilliant young engineer at
doubleclick now out of 700 Engineers if
you could pick out one person other than
Dwight you would have picked him
and so we started a company together in
2005 called shop Wiki which is a search
engine for shopping
did okay not great we sold it in 2007
made a little bit of money and then said
what are we gonna do next and so came up
with this idea uh started working on it
it was a very hard slog it's very easy
to feel good about it right now for
three years we had zero Revenue
so not easy to keep funding going back
to VCS with zero rubber but we had a lot
of people using it so you know we broke
through that but we had some ugly
financing rounds you know especially
back in 2009 2010 that was not a good
time to be raising with no revenues uh
then finally Sequoia came in and then we
raised a lot of money and now it does
getting close to a two billion dollar
run rate
did that company make you a billionaire
so yeah I mean look for all of us it
definitely uh yeah we all made lots of
money on that on that company definitely
those three years with no Revenue uh at
the time were you like people just don't
understand that this thing is uh like
others don't see it but I see it or were
you like in the fog of War you're like I
don't know if this was a thing if this
is gonna make it but um you know let's
keep going no no I would say that all of
us were nervous because uh yeah you like
to have Revenue when you're gonna run
out of money at some point what helped
us on the inside was that uh the
utilization the number of people using
the product it was free was growing
every single month all over the world so
there's you know probably 50 000 small
companies using the product and so you
know there were hundreds of meetups
about and people were showing up
and we can see in a way that the dogs
like the dog food uh we just needed to
then make it good enough that larger
companies would pay money
for it and then we got there and and the
rest is history but what's crazy is like
all right Business Insider I understand
that well that's media I get it
perfectly guilt that's Commerce that's
fairly easy to understand Zola the kind
of media-ish related but like I feel
like I understand that business and then
you have like psychedelics which I don't
have anything about but then is
like highly technical I I I barely I
don't I I don't even know the use case
to be honest it's a database company it
involves SQL like I don't even I'm so
not technical it's pretty amazing that
like are you are you pretty I mean you
are now but were you well versed on what
this idea was or did you just trust
Elliot so Ellie and Dwight you know were
the brains and the technical jobs like
the product could not have been built
without them
Ani understood the high level problem
which I saw which is that Oracle was not
the right database for the future
because we were going from structured
data to unstructured data it's the way
to think of that is that if I you know
you think of a spreadsheet which is how
we all thought about data but if I told
you I have 10 000 videos can you put
that into your spreadsheet and you're
like well no actually it's not built for
that but of course data was moving that
way YouTube came out in 2005 video was
gonna be enormous uh so I knew that
Trend was happening I knew that the
Oracle product was extraordinarily
expensive for us and so there had to be
a cheaper way we had seen Linux come out
so that was an open source you know
operating system that was enormously
successful and so we thought
collectively that we needed an open
source database that uh was was
structured for the future and so that
was the bad so that I understand if you
said five levels down do I understand
the code no but you know I was working
anytime you start a company you know
like I'm not a particularly good writer
Henry is uh and he was in charge of that
product I knew the market well enough in
both cases high level and then it's
about assembling the team you got to
think of yourself as you're the coach
you are not the player
and if you're a coach and if you managed
to persuade you know LeBron James and
Kevin Garnett and a bunch of people on
your team your team's gonna do well
that's actually the job you um you like
with the when you're talking about
transcend and you're like we've got a
drug going through FDA trials I had the
same reactions I think Sam's having
which is like man this guy's pretty
Fearless like goes into totally
different spaces with totally different
business models
and um with probably a whole bunch of
like new things you got to learn
um and even if you're the coach you know
you're betting money and you need to be
able to recruit the right players and
you need to steer the ship
um do you feel like fearlessness is
something you have and do you do you
notice that like
do you feel like sometimes I look at
other entrepreneurs and I think man I
can't believe that more of them are not
doing X do you feel like that about the
way you approach entrepreneurship like I
don't know I feel like more people
should be trying they're thinking this
way but they don't seem to I mean look
what we do is just a slight variation of
an entrepreneur they just happen to have
entrepreneurs working for me and we have
a structure and and don't forget we also
have you know I have 70 Engineers who
work for me I have my own in-house
outsourced engineering company which
helps us build product now very quickly
which we've had the last three years uh
I own a big chunk of a search firm 10
person executive Search firm that we set
up so that we can get some of the best
talent working for us finding CEOs so
we've built infrastructure around it but
still most of it goes back to a good
idea and uh a good T and when we get
that right yes and by the way last one
on psyched out yeah I had done plenty of
work I mean I'm not a scientist but I've
gone through the academic papers I know
the state of research inside Alex I know
it's working and look what I am thinking
about all the time and everyone here
does is where is the world going to be
in 10 years that's the North Star for
what we're doing if something's going to
happen next year it's too late
I need to bet on a 10-year Trend so you
know we do a bunch of things in robotics
and automation because I feel good about
that Trend it's like you know this is a
10-year Trend mongodb was a 10-year
friend
um these are things we were betting on
what are you consuming on a daily basis
to spot these Trends yeah so tons of
things no one thing I'm on you know many
many newsletters that are industry
focused or general focused or science or
is I I read 40 books a year I'm in
conversations with people all the time
where you're you know there's a lot of
learning uh and then people on my team
are more specialized than I am so you
know I have two MD mbas who are head up
our Healthcare practice and then people
below them that have worked in
healthcare so they're thinking of very
specific issues that I probably wouldn't
wouldn't think of
and the same is drive a person on
Marketplace is the person on
semiconductors and Material Science and
a person on developer tools and
enterprise software and two people on
social impact so a lot of what we do is
in those areas and I'm a bigger and
bigger believer now of Industry Focus
you know it's a you know you and I are
not going to think of something that
applies to the chemical industry right
now
but if that's all you did for six months
and interviewed 100 people you'd
probably come up with some ideas that
make sense and the industries that you
care about right now are Health
Healthcare uh uh it definitely uh then
the ones I mentioned so semiconductor is
a material science developer tools uh
with some security
marketplaces B2B marketplaces uh social
impact and Robotics and automation
what's an example of a B2B Marketplace
that you're interested in yeah so we
invest we have done a deep dive into the
maritime industry
so shipping no one thinks about it multi
100 billion dollars very behind in
technology we invested in a company
called box Hub that's a Marketplace for
those containers that are in container
ships
based in Toronto uh most people wouldn't
have known about it we LED that round we
also have just started a company in
Maritime that's going to be a a
procurement Marketplace so you're a ship
let's say you're arriving in Cartagena
your boiler breaks what are you gonna do
yeah you weren't planning on that and so
having a site you can go to that becomes
sort of the Amazon of that and as
delivery and can get you those parts uh
everyone in the industry told us that
that's needed so we're literally just
built the team two months ago there are
probably at four people right now and so
we're off and running what's that
company called it doesn't have its
official name yet
so all right let's use that as an
example so you basically did uh did you
just go and somehow Network your way
into talking to 50 oh yeah so a woman on
my team uh absolutely did that and went
to two uh Maritime conferences
so which she said were fascinating it's
basically people from Venezuela you know
the Middle East Russia you know from all
over the world Greek and so trying to
understand the industry just about the
Pirates
hobble it around and a bunch of parents
that bird all over the place she
said it did not look like her Princeton
uh reunion at all
so yeah and so and she met with the
couple investors who invest in this
space you know ship owners uh data
providers everyone you're just trying to
understand how does this industry work
and I think there's an advantage
sometimes coming from outside
because some people just say oh that's
just how it works here and the person on
the outside will be like wait a second
it doesn't have to work that way you
know we can do better right and that's
why like you know Henry was the perfect
person coming from outside you know when
I started guilt none of my initial five
people had worked in the fashion
industry
but we understood the problem it wasn't
that complicated so we could create
something that was that was interesting
and unusual uh so that's the right
approach we just started a company in
assisted fertility I'm sure you guys
know you have friends you know who are
getting IVF I did it yeah my brother and
his Husband you know uh had a child
through surrogacy
freezing eggs that's gonna grow for the
next 10 years for all the reasons we
know about people having children later
sperm counts are down much things so we
do we saw we started copy what uh four
months ago we put in a million half
dollars and we just signed a term sheet
to raise you know five and a half
million dollars
um a lot of people wanted to do it
people are excited about the team uh we
have you know good set of people uh
mostly from Stanford Business School on
this team and it's a big space
so uh I'm gonna bet on that team and
that trend for a while what does that
deck look like you said they they do
like a or maybe I think a 50 page memo
or deck I'm not sure what you said do
you have a structure for it
yeah it's generally one just talking
about the industry where are the
problems where are the pain points and
then where are the opportunities what's
the product idea so one of the reasons I
do almost nothing in e-commerce these
days is because I don't see the problem
we saw the industry solve the problem I
mean if you name anything on the planet
Earth just about you know you can find a
site they'll have ten thousand of them
it'll be sent to your house by tomorrow
man I don't know how to do better that
problem is solved
whereas when I yeah when I started guilt
you actually couldn't get Marc Jacobs at
50 off online uh just no one offered it
and so we offered it and people went
crazy over that uh so e-commerce is very
mature frankly media is pretty mature
right now there's a lot you know nothing
people say to me I just can't find what
I want to want to read uh but even you
know once in a while we're working on
one idea right now the early stages in
the media space uh but not not sure yet
so we're looking for problems the health
one of the reasons I like healthcare
is because
it Healthcare is not solved you know as
you guys know you have knee surgery
either you or your insurance company are
going to pay a crazy amount one there's
too much knee surgery it's gonna
someone's gonna pay 40 000 yet in France
it's 20 000 and the results are better
so can it be done better yes it can be
done better you're 20 times more black
women die in childbirth than in Sweden
yes is that something that is just
inherent and is always going to happen
no we don't do enough prevention there
are many structural issues in health
care that have not been solved and we're
we're solving some of them
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
it sounds to me like what you do is you
look think about what's the world going
to look like in 10 years
um yeah you know either what's a problem
that just if somebody could solve it
that would be a major major unlock or
hey the puck is going this way
and then then it sounds like you say
um
cool let's go find out everything we can
learn about that space we we go in kind
of uh open-minded about what problem
we're gonna solve we try to figure out
uh where all the pain points are and
then it sounds like you're looking for
what I'll call the big obvious problem
which is if it's too complicated and
nuanced it doesn't sound like you're
that interested it's like uh hey you
can't find luxury fashion online for 50
off right okay that's like a big obvious
problem it doesn't take that much
explaining or expertise to even
understand the problem maybe the
solution might be might take some
expertise but the problem should be in
your face uh once once you're looking in
that industry
um we uh we have this thing we say on
the podcast which is that there are
businesses that their business plans
that are what I call one chart
businesses you could just look at one
chart and it just tells you oh that's
yep that's so obvious like we were
looking at one that was around
um uh in the death space around
cremation it was like cremation went
from I don't know seven percent of all
things to like 50 it's now the majority
of uh of of of what choices people make
when um when it comes to a funeral
and this is like that's a one-chart
business you can look at nothing else
and say all right I know there's big I
know there's opportunity when I look at
a chart like this
um is is that does that jive with your
way of thinking or do you have anything
you can add to our understanding of that
no no absolutely I mean I'll give you
another one the cost of Labor
is going to just keep going up and so
you know waiters were paid 15 an hour
now it's 20 to 25 an hour in New York
unless we change immigration or
something funnily change is that could
be thirty dollars an hour so you know
what over time that changes the calculus
of automation whether it's making french
fries whether it's through this we're
all going to have to find ways to use
less Labor uh and so when cost of tech
goes down and the cost of Labor goes up
what does that tell you more automation
is going to happen
uh so I'll bet on that Trend all day
long yeah we're an investor in a company
that gives robotic massages there's a 17
000 open positions for massage
therapists in this country
and so you know there's hotels that just
can't offer massages because they don't
have the people so you know we hope
they're going to offer a massage so
that's just one example but I have 10
others we uh well what are those 10
others uh of just of just automation or
other ideas no just I'll give you
another example another company we
invested in is so driverless cars is you
know as you know not legal in most
countries most States but having a
remote driver is
so would you if you're in New York City
would you pay money to have a car a
rental car brought to your apartment as
opposed to you having to take your seven
suitcases and two kids and go to the
rental car of course you would
um and yet we can have someone in the
Philippines or in you know Arizona drive
the car because we put software and
Hardware in the in the car they can see
everything that's legal in many states
uh Airport's already talking to us uh
about
um the vans that they have to drive
around to bring people to the rental car
lots at two in the morning hardly anyone
on there you got to pay someone double
time 40 bucks an hour that should be
done by someone remotely so things like
that are going to be automated
so Sean and I um we've had a bunch of
cool people on this podcast so one of
our great friends is this guy named
Andrew Wilkinson he owns maybe 40
companies a lot of agencies and web
stuff mostly bootstrapped it's publicly
traded now and then we had this other
guy named Saeed who's like 32 years old
who owns um a bunch of Wordpress plugins
basically that bootstrapped a unicorn
wow amazing and well of what she owns
most of
um and so we have a lot of like and and
I fall in this category as well I I
bootstrap a lot of my things
um and then there's this other category
so there's a category people who like
bootstrap stuff and then she's their
cash flow and then oftentimes that same
group of people prefer to go and buy
companies as opposed to build them from
scratch you're taking the opposite
approach a little bit where you're like
uh I'm gonna fund it it's not gonna make
money at first but I and I might go and
raise a a ton more money but this
might be a huge idea and I'll own a
small piece of it
what um like have you ever considered
the bootstrapping model or is your is
your you just go big right away and have
you ever considered buying what's your
like buy versus build kind of mindset
yeah so it really depends on the type of
business so if you're running an agency
you just don't need a lot of capital you
know you hire five people who uh and
then they that agencies make money and
then you use that money to reinvest and
grow if you're building what I'm
building is closer to like a hotel you
know you have to build the whole
building before anyone comes and stays
with you so a little different because
like you got to take years to
build a good enough product and there's
no way to bootstrap that you know it
takes
2050 you know there's a hundred million
dollars generally for those types of
companies to get there so that's why
it's it's not an option for those things
look I would love to have companies that
you know I that own all of for example
the the agency that I have I said those
Engineers I basically have an outsourced
engineering company I own all of that uh
because it has clients and it bills as
it gets more clients like those visits
are not a scalable profit margins are
generally lower
um those are not typing businesses I
generally go after why is that is it
just a matter of you just enjoy
something more do you think that one is
a better better wealth creation are you
I mean what's the motivation I just
prefer creating a product a real product
that's hard uh and then you know making
more scalable and building it up over
time the vast majority of quite
successful companies are in that
category the services oriented companies
you know it's harder it's harder to get
to be a unicorn it can happen but there
aren't there aren't that many over time
gotten more selective on the project
selection because I look at you know you
did Business Insider I think you were
the C were you the CEO for like a period
of time there nine years is that right
no no I was the chairman for all nine
years
I did step in I did step in to be the
CEO of guilt when we were growing really
quickly I just decided that I was the
right person at that point for probably
two or three years but otherwise I've
been chairman of many companies for 15
years I stepped into I changed
CEOs about eight years ago uh and for
three months I was de facto the CEO as I
was doing so you've run these for period
of time but mostly not um but but I
guess uh when I think about businesses I
look at my career and it's like I look
back and I think okay of these 10 things
I did
two of them were like ate up all of my
time and gave me a bunch of gray hair
for like relatively less payoff versus
these other two which was like I just
kind of wrote the check it was an
obvious opportunity and it just paid me
and it was wonderful have you like
what's the best business that you've
done in your portfolio that you look
back on that has the combination of the
value the pain that it took to get there
you know um all of that and then
do you have a framework around there or
do you think it's just luck at the draw
and he's like the draw I mean is
the one where you know I got the most
return for the least amount of money I
mean I essentially never worked there
full time uh so chairman for 13 years
um and yet it's super valuable and you
know fascinating company that's going to
be around for the next 50 years uh but
you know I'm intellectually curious so
what I love about what I do is that you
know in an hour I might be in a meeting
on psychedelics and then on you know
semiconductors and I have to try and
keep up and learn something about these
um and that's what so you know we have
one in cardiology uh there's so many
different things it's that's what's
amazing and for someone who's thinking
about 10 years I'm
a little surprise I don't see AI all
over this doc uh you know you're not
saying it sounds like it might be
embedded in some of these things that
you're doing uh like might be a tool you
use but are you bearish on it for some
reason or what's your thinking around AI
no I say two things one it's coming down
now but if it were six months ago you
know the pricing on AI was insane now
three people walk in and say we're worth
100 million dollars because we're gonna
put together an AI company just didn't
make sense so we didn't make any direct
Investments there
um each we're really encouraging each
one of our companies to use Ai and I
think them you know the really use of AI
in the short term is going to be much
more mundane it's optimizing customer
support you know making your coding more
efficient and things like that uh we're
a long ways before you know true AI
companies are coming but it's but it's
on its way we did something unusual this
summer The our entire technology team
shut down for a week
went home and their only assignment was
to learn about AI the entire week read
about it think about it talk to people
John did that too yeah I did the same
thing I shut down for a week yeah just
to get up to speed because it is a very
important thing that we all need to be
thinking about and then came back you
know compared notes and made sure that
our our companies are thinking did you
do it too or just the engineers
no these are not Engineers this is the
the investment people on the on the tech
side so I do it on a more continual
basis you know I'm spread thinner than
other people so you know I have 60 board
meetings a year I have a lot of things I
have to I can't shut down as easily
unless I'm a burning man in Orange
yeah as one does nice Flex I love that
then I'm done then I'm off the grid and
I don't have a choice
I'm going to change all of my uh my my
uh auto reply things to I'm in
Antarctica even though I'm just actually
in time the only two times I'm truly off
to it you uh you you like violate this
rule that I have for myself and uh you
you do it so wonderfully which is focus
or at least it appears as as you do you
like launch like I don't know how many
companies a year do you launch eight
eight goddamn and you could do eight now
but I don't know how big your team was
early on but it seemed like you were
still creating a lot of companies I mean
generally it was one a year one a year
um there was that one year we did three
between the two of us uh but I would
never be able to do eight on my own I
mean they take real time
if we are if the roles were reverse you
know I look up to you if you were a 23
year old and you looked up to me I would
say man you got to do one thing well and
that will pay more dividends I agree oh
well great so what's your like opinion
on that then no no so I think that
anyone I I and people come to me all the
time and say look I would like to have a
studio like you and I'd say look don't
do that start by trying to start a
successful company and end up not being
the CEO that's already not that easy you
know if you have that and six months
later the company has raised its
external round of financing has a full
management team in place and you are the
chairman you can then decide to do
another one you know you can't truly be
CEO of multiple companies but you can be
chairman of multiple companies but you
got to start with one and you try and do
two or three at the same time on your
own it's not going to work it's not that
easy you know I have 25 people what does
the chairman actually do
so a chairman is one the in this case is
the ultimate person that's going to be
around 15 years from now the CEO may
change
this is a person that's going to guide
it and as a co-founder
you know if along the way somehow Henry
Lodge had quit that's my problem I need
to find a CEO I need to solve that for
the board so you're just the most active
board member we had other investors but
everyone knows the guy one company that
is gonna have a tricky financing round
and uh we need to get the in the uh the
internal investors together not going to
be easy I need to do that so I'm having
calls with all them I need to Wrangle
everyone encourage them push them come
up with the right thing what type of
relationship do you have with your CEOs
like before it's like uh you know in the
first one two three four years how often
are you working with them yeah so I mean
there uh we're gonna have a call
probably every week or every two weeks
soon to touch base and then they reach
out if they need something
I mean I love the relationship I feel
great about the relationship because you
know I don't want their job I wanted a
job I would have I would have taken
their job
um I want them to succeed I don't you
know I don't want to be CEO of one
company and hopefully I can stay out of
the way because they know much more
about the company than I do but there's
certain things where I have either
relationship some experience tricky
issues uh uh introduction to a VC firm
where I can add value uh and so I I love
that relationship
uh I like you so much because you do
things okay so Sean and I are in this
like stupid Twitter world where like a
lot of our friends are popular on the
internet yeah and there's this whole
thing that I don't buy into of like
build in public and like use your
audience but like it's people selling
like 100 a month things or something
like that and you have these like really
big ideas but also like for how
successful you are we take pride in like
finding interesting people who are like
amazing but not incredibly well known
you are really good you're one of the
higher people on this ratio of like
pretty low-key under the radar but has
had massive impact it's exactly what I
want and like you don't have an audience
like you you violate all these like
stupid rules that people talk about I do
no social media why is that you know
it's I look I think other people use it
very well and they like doing it I don't
want to spend the time uh I don't want
to do it I don't want to I don't need to
be out there uh I that time should be
used for thinking time and managing time
uh and so yeah no the people are on my
marketing team know that the goal is
that we are very successful and that
when I walk into a restaurant no one
knows who I am yeah I mean I just think
it's awesome well I I but you you're on
like CNBC and like that every once
in a while I'll see you there I think
there's rumors that you're you're gonna
run for mayor is that true so yeah
choose everything one is you haven't
seen me on TV in a long time
right yeah that was you that was about
four or five years ago I think I was
like leaving your office or something
like that in the Yahoo building or maybe
I was at a friends I saw you on TV yeah
I don't think I've been on for at least
five years so yeah I don't yeah you know
actually podcasts are the only thing I
do because it's sort of enjoyable you
don't need to prepare you have a good
conversation uh so I've done that but I
other than that I do almost nothing I
did uh think about running for mayor you
know eight years ago I've been very
involved in politics in many ways
um representing Tech Community and in
every Dimension
um
all my life I thought I would want it
that'd be the one other thing I'd want
to do and then decided you know seven
years ago that I didn't want to do that
it's it's a miserable process you know
if you said to me you could be mayor
tomorrow I would actually do it and you
said to me no no what I mean is that you
can be one of seven candidates you can
spend eight months getting the
kicked out of you and being humiliated
you're like uh I'm gonna be in
Antarctica that week sorry guys like can
we do this next week no we're not you're
you're telling me I can't go see my kids
who are you know at various points all
over the world and I get to see them all
the time uh we do great things together
uh and so that's a big trade-off that I
don't want to make anymore so I'm gonna
keep doing what I'm doing for a long
time you were involved in one company
um that I always that I think could
still work and it didn't work uh but you
almost had it so you invested or were a
board member you're heavily involved I
think in hot jobs which they had an exit
but you do this other one called uh the
ladder or ladders yeah where at the this
was in the mid 2000s where like a
hundred thousand dollar job was
considered good and it was like I think
if I remember correctly I don't remember
if the user paid or if the job company
paid but it was a job board that's kind
of dismissing it but it was a job site
for a hundred thousand dollar jobs yep
and I remember seeing that I was like
that's pretty cool and I tried launching
a company where the user would pay a
subscription
and then editorial person would try to
survey and uh and effectively find out
what it's like to work there as opposed
to the company uh like telling you the
best the best um like you know like the
best stuff but I always you're always in
you had a couple companies in like the
job space I've always thought that that
was pretty cool and I always thought
that could have been done effectively I
remember the was it ladders or the
ladders the ladders and it's still
around but not nearly as successful as
it was it started in 2004 I was one of
the early early investors uh and it's
it's actually still there I lost you
know LinkedIn basically you know did a
much better job
I'm an investor in Ripple match which is
uh a jobs oriented company aiming at
people in college the job situation is
still not fully solved and that's going
to be one where uh you know AI will be
used intelligently as a recruiter as you
know it takes enormous time
to figure out the 50 resumes you should
look at reach out and say can I have a
phone conversation with you respond to
that hours and hours and hours and hours
and hours and that needs to be you know
productized uh and we're on our way we
being my company as well as many others
has alicorp ever taken any financing or
are you strictly using your winnings
like and how much did you use to fund
the company when you first started yeah
I did hear that much but I yo I've
invested probably 250 million dollars
into the various companies over the
years
and that came from like the the various
the sale yeah but but do you take cash
flow from anything or is it strictly you
yeah is your income lumpy or not your
personal income but no I I don't I
haven't gotten paid in a long time I'm
purely just investing my own money but I
have all infrastructure and a whole firm
that does that so it's like it has
historically been a single LP fund
everyone has carry it's no different
than you into our Ventures or Thrive or
anything else just has one LP instead of
many what are you looking to change or
improve so if we talk to you 10 years
from now what do you hope what do you
hope is different about you or your
lifestyle or your businesses that versus
today
so I'm doing most of the things I want
to do now so
one you know it's going very well
results have been great I spend three to
four months a year in Europe working
from there I grew up in Europe my wife
is French uh uh I have one child there
uh and I I enjoy that so I'm planning on
continuing that I want to keep doing
various you know athletic and
interesting trips around that that you
know that that I enjoy so from a high
level I'm not planning on changing it
dramatically the I'd actually love what
I'm doing I think we're having fun and
we're going to continue to do this I
don't want to make it much bigger
you know I don't want to have that many
more people that'll just make it more
sort of system oriented where I'm not
close to the companies because what I
enjoy is when I'm close to the companies
and the problems and that's where I
think I I add value I'm just trading off
I'm very old at this point in this
industry and so I'm you know hopefully
reaping the benefits of the Judgment
that you get after dealing with these
things and making lots of mistakes along
the way but a bunch of things going well
and another thing that I like about you
is that um
you're very emotionally stable like
every time you know I've only talked to
you three times but like you were quite
logical and like you seem like a guy who
isn't rattled and I read an article
about Business Insider selling and I
think uh the article said Henry Blodgett
is a very emotional person which is
makes sense because he's a journalist
he's a great writer and during the sale
I think someone was I think he was like
I'm not even talking to Axel Springer
whoever bought it uh Kevin has to do it
yeah like I just I can't even be in that
room yeah and like it was like all right
Kevin steps in and he's the reasonable
one or he's like the emotionally uh like
I negotiated I negotiated the entire
deal uh and you know and look I could
not be a bigger fan than I am of Henry's
but
it would be like if if someone kidnapped
your daughter
uh are you a good negotiator with the
other side and the answer is no right
you're like give them everything uh yeah
we can just get her back so we need
someone else to do that and so
um it was better for me to do it he was
very nervous because I was pushing to
get a higher price uh and but which we
did you know we're doing 40 million at
the time we sold it for 11 times
revenues which is a big big number for a
media property insane yeah it's insane
we're good friends with uh one of our
best friends is Austin Reef the founder
of morning Brew yeah and and they're
they're killing it for for bi and uh
great that happened after me but great
acquisition uh I still get that product
every day I think they do a really nice
job have a great editorial tone but
you're right I'm I'm don't I mean this
I think it's important to not get too
emotional about any one company and
that's one of the things I can bring to
the table and when you're CEO you're
just so close to it you're you're you're
in the forest I can step back a little
bit and sometimes say look you know this
is gonna be bigger than you think and we
should you know double down or it's not
working and let's figure out a way to
sell this it's easier for me a question
that we uh that we like to ask people
is like what do you do with your money
so like if if you know of your of your
pie chart of your 100 portfolio how do
you how do you allocate uh
to different stuff you know do you have
public equities and just normal bonds
and stuff are you all in on private
company what are you doing all in on
private companies so probably 90 of my
net worth is just in my own Farm in
investing in various companies and
things uh I have a I have some in some
VC and private Equity firms you know as
an LP
uh you know and I do have some real
estate uh I bought a building a
commercial real estate building uh
between on Mott and Broome in between
Soho and Bowery and so when you come
visit in a year that'll be the alley
Corp headquarters there'll be a
restaurant in the in a in the in the
retail floor five floors of commercial
real estate and an amazing roof deck
with parties for 150 people and dinners
for 30 people up there so it's gonna be
a real Tech Center
so we're it was a shell of a building
and construction starts in a week we've
designed it over the last nine months
it's a super fun project but it's also a
diversification for me and owning some
real estate but you don't have any
Public public equities no other than I
imagine you still own stock in uh uh
mango yes but but like you don't you
don't have any uh boring uh indexes
really are you heavy on cash
yes I always keep a lot of cash I need
to keep a lot of cash because I don't
have you know I don't have a salary so
and I don't know when money's coming
back
where do you keep your cash just in the
in the in yeah as simple as a high yield
savings account yep yep exactly I need
to be super liquid dude that's so
fascinating this is awesome Evan thanks
so much for coming on we uh as you can
tell big fans and what you've done is is
pretty incredible also I think there's
just like what you do about thinking
about where the world is going what
ideas what opportunities what problems
it's also you know the premise of our
podcast when we don't have guests on
that's all we're doing we're thinking
about that and we're we're brainstorming
what that could look like and so our
entire audience is people who like
hearing about those opportunities or
stories of people capitalizing on them
so I think this is uh you know very very
good fit thanks for thanks for doing
this great well thanks for having me on
it's just fun and again good to
reconnect
and I hope you realize like I'm not just
talking like you had a really big
you you've had a big impact in my life
and um I'm gonna be following a bunch of
stuff that you do and and I have this
document that I it's like uh 500 500
Words of the notes that I took and I
talked to and I've and you actually
predicted that how much we were going to
get acquired for by the way you nailed
it yeah you nailed it
um you said I think in two years gonna
get bought for about this much you
nailed it uh you predict two other
Acquisitions in the media space as well
in my notes I'll share it with you so
you see uh the notes but uh you've had a
really big impact on me and it's really
cool to talk to you and hopefully we can
stay in touch yeah of course we it
sounds like we need an in-person uh
meeting uh we need to get together and
and see what the next five years are
going to look like let's do it man I
would love that and and we appreciate
you thanks for coming on all right
thanks
[Music]
thank you